even though we shouldn't judge everybody  judges okay I remember a friend of mine  Fernando lasso and uh the singer yeah  the singer the famous singer which by  the way he's coming down to visit to uh  Florida so first time I get a job at  Hollywood valleys back then I was in  shape and I was like this was I wanted  to be it was my life just got out of the  army I walk in he sees me says this guy  just looks like a [ __ ] he just looks  like somebody that's arrogant that's  this that's that I'm gonna have a hard  time working with you we became best  friends the guy was one of my groomsmen  am I winning some some people are going  to have that look and they're gonna say  you look like somebody that would be  like that of course and the next thing  you know I like this guy